right here hurt her to inbound for the
haunts
young standing at the elbow
he got knocked to the court galinari
gets the inbound pass
drives it tough mid-range no good and
that's going to do it the mavericks get
the defensive stop
at the end of the game young furious
with the officiating
felt that he was pushed down and got hit
in the face
showing the official there where he got
hit
that he might be bleeding
that's not a foul though mark he set a
screen and a good one
kali stein did not blow it up that's
that's not a foul
okay yeah this was in the aftermath and
you see young walk right to the official
i'm with you jeff i don't think he was
hit that hard and
that's not an nba foul in the last five
seconds
he tried to draw and exaggerate the
contact and he wasn't rewarded
it was an excellent screen collins was
actually open
on the lob and then golin got a pretty
good look but good
defense by hardaway jr
so you think you got to throw that lob
if you're kevin heard her because
collins did seem to be open there for
just enough right
well it was a good screen by young it
got him separation now hardaway reacted
but i thought it was a good screen and
it was open
so look at the final tally from young
and doncic
doncic outscores young young with
more assists but the only number that
really matters in the end
is the win for the dallas mavericks
another critical win as they begin to
gain a little bit of momentum
they've now won three in a row at home
after losing six straight in dallas